we are with the defending Champion the
2021 Champion Wesley so Wesley welcome
back uh to the studio tell us a bit how
did you leave this first round at the
USGS championships
um well I'm
slightly disappointed obviously not to
get the game but at the same time it's a
long tournament also remember uh
I think this is my seventh youth
Championship if I'm correct played one
online also like uh it's always a tough
tournament and like last year remember
had difficult game with Blackman against
Jeffrey made the solid draw and then
things went well in the tournament
um so
it actually started thinking after move
one after his move E4
and yasu was a bit confused why we took
like a minute and a half to play E5 why
why'd you do that oh yeah well good
question well actually I was just
looking at some of the words because
there was a long line the day on the
scanners so like Fabi was a few minutes
late because he was in line I think some
other players
so so it had nothing to do with us yeah
Jeff I just also wanted to see like
other openings like uh Darius were
explaining the slab against Jefferson
when he normally doesn't and also the
Neiman game with the Knights theater
Bishop F4 so I was just waiting to see
also I thought we'd get another better
of
a theoretical battle in the linear game
body versus linear yeah but but yeah
it's a good question because
um
actually I wonder told me he's in
studying in the University of Chicago
right now so he's missed three weeks of
school and he told me it's a bit Rusty
but I didn't know this before the game
so
um in hindsight maybe I should have
considered playing other openings such
as the Sicilian but I wonder if
predominantly E4 player and I played my
usual opening but um obviously when
you're playing some a lower rated player
I mean very strong but lower rated uh
they it could happen that they would be
happy to to get a draw and uh you know
getting out there with black for me is
also not such a bad deal but uh I feel
that was the case in this game given the
opening okay in hindsight maybe I should
have played another opening because a
Wonder hasn't played a lot of Chess
recently you know how being a college
student feels like you've been to
college student once yeah it can it can
be a professional player and a college
student it means too much classes and
your professors don't know anything
about you maybe nowadays they do but
back then and you know so you guys went
into this super long line Bishop to D2
you played it as white did not surprise
you right yeah I played a couple times
against Magnus
um
also
well the problems I wonder is very good
in the opening like obviously today he
came extremely well prepared so when he
played Bishop dito I started thinking
like to play something else
or to go for this long line with Bishop
takes theater and I decided it's the
first round you know uh wasn't
X of course I didn't predict that he
would go for this line before before the
game but I had such a narrow opening
repair toward that you know
it's not a surprise when someone says
something new
um the funny part was I played this
position twice with white against Magnus
and both games I got the worst position
with white so
but this game is a well-known draw
um but in any case it's just the first
round in this U.S Championship is
extremely long it's almost as long as or
it's actually as long as why can't they
speak to me about that for a second you
mentioned at the beginning of the
interview that this new format with 14
players instead of 12 players is going
to be different what do you mean by that
uh well there's two more days right
there's two more games uh normally these
days I think an average classical term
is around 10 days long I think 13 games
is a bit too long uh also now you you
have more lower rated players than than
last year uh
uh I mean it's fine but you have to like
conserve your energy preserve your
energy because you know uh people
question why make early draws and stuff
but you have to realize that we play
every single day and you also prepare
beforehand
um so I think like 11 games is long
enough for this Championship but this
year is an exception I was actually
talking to James Star John yesterday
who's one of the inductees
in the Hall of Fame
and he told me in the old days US
championships last 16 games yes last
almost a month old school yeah yeah but
but they didn't have a to prepare with a
computer in those days and uh looking
without looking at Electronics before
game can be very tiring Wesley
congratulations a smooth start for you
still plenty of games to go we'll let
you rest yeah I think also like I played
the online a couple days ago against
Jefferson so oh yeah that was a big
battle yeah that was awesome yeah in the
playoffs yeah I got very lucky but uh
um
no but yeah one day at a time one day at
a time thank you very much Wesley thank
you Wesley uh just a quick comment and
maybe you could follow up with a comment
of your own yesterday at the opening
ceremony I saw you taking uh pictures
with an inductee Eugene
you look like uh you were really
enjoying uh being with eugeno and uh
honoring him and as he was inducted to
the World Chess Hall of Fame your
thoughts about Eugene OR getting into
the World Chess Hall of Fame
a good friend of mine I mean obviously
we haven't
uh talk to each other in a long time but
he was one of the few people who
supported me a lot when I switched
federations and he's one of my not
officially my chess coach but it's one
of my uh
very early coaches
he was the official team coach in the
2003 World dude and also I think in 2004
and 2005
so he's
he was one of the players that I really
look up to on learning chef and he's
helped me a lot he's given me plenty of
advice and
giving me chess books when I was young
so he's
I'm really thankful he's one of the most
decent man in chess that you could look
up to and he's also played 22 Olympians
if if I'm correct which is an insane
amount I I think he's a very talented
player and I think he could have gone
farther if he maybe twitch federations
like
but uh but yeah he meant I've known him
and his wife for a long time now and
they're gonna be here for they're gonna
be touring the United States for for a
few days and uh maybe I think we're
we're planning to have dinner with them
one night maybe tonight because I
finished very early but uh but certainly
he's a legend first Asian Grandmaster uh
and he's also one of the seconds of
Bobby Fisher in the 1992 match
so he's uh he's overall a great guy and
I think he still plays chess very well
it's three things around 24 50.
thank you for those kind words
absolutely Eugene a really really a
chess Legend and I I known him since the
80s and uh always a good guy good guy to
be around exactly